talk about your relationship with greedo
because you obviously you know
three greedo's got
12 000 songs that no one's heard yet
free my boy greedo so me and greedo got
a whole project together right so when
greedo was uh
because you know greedo been out for a
long time yeah he's been doing for a
long time he's been out for a long time
but when he started blowing up as uh
greedo
and like [ __ ] was oni you know
what i mean uh
i remember he was talking that [ __ ] yeah
i just did 12 songs today oh i did 20
songs today so i'm like the next time we
get in the studio like i'm competitive
you know what i'm saying like that's how
the g worthy project came about but
we'll talk about that but like when we
get in the studio i'm like man this
[ __ ] not about to run circles
around me in here you know what i'm
saying so every time a beat came on
i'm trying to rush in the booth cause he
just
he hear the beat and he just casually
walks in the booth
and comes out in five minutes that's
what the [ __ ] done you know what i'm
saying
when when it when everything come on i'm
trying to i'm rushing in there you know
what i mean and we uh at the end of the
night we ended up with a project one of
the songs came out on uh
uh first a good job first yeah fkr first
shot he dropped he dropped one of the
songs that we did that night and um
and we still probably got about like 15
songs in my computer and [ __ ]
um
probably dropped some more of that [ __ ]
but that's basically what that so his
creative process is
have you ever seen anyone record that
fast because i mean from what uh it's
tight no tk was telling me like the
amount of songs he has um
it's insane yeah
like it's almost like you don't believe
it until you see like damn i like this
guy's drops music like he's still a
[ __ ] machine i think he just learned
how to just have a conversation not like
he just learned how to be like one with
music if that makes sense like because
like he bro he's i know for sure he's
not thinking hard about nothing the beat
come on
he talking [ __ ] yeah
walk in and then walk back out like you
know i'm saying the only time i seen him
like
like pressure and that ain't even
pressure was like when he pressing the
engineer like give my [ __ ] sounding
right
like what i'm saying but outside of that
he like that nigga's like water like he
just wouldn't you uh the
joint project that you're sitting on is
there any sort of idea when that's gonna
um we've been talking about it she's on
your your album a couple times right
yeah he on there um he called me one day
and [ __ ]
and um and he like man put out some of
that [ __ ] and i thought about it
so i took a uh
jay nori actually took a piece from um
one of the joints and uh makes it into
too sexy and um
[Music]
and uh we just had a conversation and
[ __ ] we was talking i'm like i'ma record
it you know what i'm saying and we just
talking [ __ ]
and i'll chop pieces from the
conversation and put them inserts on
certain songs